all right fig lovers this is Ross the
Fig boss and today's video we're going
to talk about why your fig tree isn't
Fring and how to fix that in fact this
is actually probably the most common
question that I get people message me
all the time on my blog my YouTube
channel I get emails messages you name
it about why their fig tree isn't Fring
and usually people will include
photos uh show me the pictures of their
trees their leaves and I just always see
the same common bread but it's not
really what you think it's it's not
water or a lack of water it's not
usually a lack of Health it's not a lack
of sunlight or fertilizer or this or
that that a lot of you guys probably
would
immediately think about it's actually
something called hormones plant hormones
yes I'm I'm not kidding plants actually
have hormones as well I've talked a lot
about them here on this channel and
actually I've written up a detailed
article that's a companion guide to this
video I highly recommend you guys check
it out the link will be in the
description you can go right to my blog
and read into more detail in depth about
what we're talking about today but the
hormones are really critical in all
Fring plants not just and flowering
plants too not just the Fig Tree in fact
when we think about how to encourage
other fruit trees to actually fruit and
flower the main thing that people
actually talk about is actually pruning
and that's why I have my pruning shears
with me today because one of the things
that people say is actually to do summer
pruning and that the not
necessarily how much pruning you do but
actually the timing in which you do your
prunning makes a big difference and that
if I come in here to these cherry trees
that you see and I do this summer
pruning technique where I remove about a
third
to even a half of the new growth these
trees are going to be more likely to
fruit The Following season and it's
pretty brain dead all we do is just go
around to all the branches of the trees
and remove about a third to a half of
that new growth believe it or not this
tricks the trees into having a different
balance of hormones that encourages them
not to grow a lot next year but to
actually flower and fruit the next year
now it may take a couple year or two do
with these cherry trees because of the
way that they fruit but the Fig is no
different and that if we can actually
come in here during the summer we would
encourage our fig trees to fruit and
flour but we don't summer prune fig
trees any everybody knows that if you
have a fig tree we don't summerun them
because the weird thing about fig trees
is that they actually produce fruit on
the new growth of the season so if I
came in here to this cherry tree and and
I removed all the new
growth well that would be like removing
all the cherries off the
tree so we can't do the same thing with
the Fig maybe you know after actually
the Fig Tree fruits and it's done
fruiting if you guys live in really long
season season climates like Southern
California really hot and dry places you
can come in actually after they fruit
and prune them really far back and that
can actually encourage them to put out a
second flush of growth will then produce
even more fig believe it or not but
typically again we're not summer pruning
fig trees and the only real pruning that
we do is actually during the winter time
but if we winter prune our fig trees the
balance of hormones instead of Shifting
towards flowering it shifts towards
growing and that's what causes our trees
to have this issue is that balance of
hormones the Fig because of this is
really
particular about its hormones now I've
seen fig trees that can fruit in six to
eight months from cutting you put a
cutting in the ground six to eight
months later you got a lot of figs on
your tree uh I've seen them many of them
fruit in the first year the second year
the third year uh it's pretty rare that
we have a fig tree that isn't fruiting
by the third fourth or fifth year and if
that's the case with your tree I get
this all the time Ross I have a big
beautiful just Lush gorgeous it's just
the best looking fig tree and but all it
does is grow it doesn't fruit and it's x
amount of years old this is probably why
and that we're doing the wrong kind of
pruning either the timing is off it's
the wrong kind of pruning which I'll
discuss in a minute or it's actually the
fact that you have a lots of winter
damage yes the winter is the same thing
as pruning our trees so if our the
winter comes in brings these branches
back it's the same thing as winter
pruning the trees have no idea of the
difference all they know is that they
lost some of their limbs and they lost
them in a particular order in a
particular way and so what happens if we
have here's how you prune a fig tree in
the winter time to ensure that you're
going to have successful fruit set the
next year
so keeping the trees in Balance we have
two different ways we can prune them and
my fingers here are going to be the
example so we have heading Cuts that's
the first style of pruning that probably
most of you guys have done today and
that you take your pruning shears and
you just cut across a certain height and
you make the cut all the way across the
top just like I did with these cherry
trees I cut out a third of the growth I
cut out a half of the growth we took a
chainsaw and just leveled all the trees
out at a certain height how many of you
guys have done that um you cut them at
chest height or waist height or whatever
it is and you just bring them all the
way far
back that's going to be a recipe for
disaster for getting your fig tree to
fruit the next year now I'm going to say
this it doesn't necessarily mean that it
won't fruit next year because I've done
this to my trees plenty of times some of
you guys watching right now have done
this to your trees plenty of times but
it's a balance of hormones and so even
though we can still chop them really far
back doesn't always mean it's going to
result in zero fruits but it's going to
result in zero fruits more likely than
not it depends on the tree you have the
structure of your tree the age of your
tree the variety of your tree the
climate that you're living in there are
so many factors that go into that uh but
generally speaking doing that kind of
pruning is going to result result in
less fruit set next year and years in
the future now the other kind of fing is
actually thinning Cuts where we come in
here and we actually remove the one in
the middle and we bring this by the way
all the way as far back as we
can and you leave the other two alone
you do not top them you do not head them
back you leave them alone so if we
remove the one in the center and we
bring that all the way back that can be
a way we can control the height cuz a
lot of people struggle well we're CR if
I don't want to prune my fig
tree um or if I'm doing the wrong kind
of pruning what if I just leave it alone
well if you leave it alone actually
you're going to have a more higher
chance believe it or not that it's going
to fruit but if you have to do any
pruning and you have to bring back the
height of your tree you want to do
thinning cuts and that starts always
down here at the base of our trees or
the scaffolds of our trees you remove
one of those arms you remove one of
those trunks all the way down at the
soil line as far down as you can can and
that usually is going to be the longest
tallest one you take that out a new one
comes up in its place and you just
continue this recycling process but in
that way of pruning you're not
destroying the hormones that balance of
hormones that needs to be in place for
your trees to be productive I'll tell
you this if you cut your fig tree all
the way back to 6 to 12 in some amazing
things can
happen if you cut your fig tree back
really far just in General you can get
figs that grow insanely quickly so this
might be a good thing depending on what
you guys are trying to do but back over
here on this Southern plot that I have
I've been cutting my fig trees back to 6
to 12 in for years and you may not be
able to recognize it now but I have
branches in here that were 8 to 10 feet
tall at the beginning of this season
because we cut them back last spring all
the way to the base or the winter came
in here and did it for us and that's
usually what's happening here with the
people I see that don't have productive
fruit trees or fig trees they have the
wrong kind of pruning that they're doing
they're letting the winter come in here
damage and cut the trees for them and
the only way to get this problem fixed
is to protect your fig tree throughout
the winter time for one season just one
growing season get it through through
the winter time without any damage that
way it doesn't do this heading cut
process for you you protect it through
the winter time with zero damage the
next year it's much more likely to fruit
if it still doesn't fruit at that point
you probably just have to be a little
bit patient because your variety just
takes a little bit more time than other
varieties to actually fruit and I have a
couple in here just like the ones over
there even though we've protected those
trees in the southern plot that I
mentioned there is a about five or six
trees in there that will not fruit this
year even though we did exactly what we
needed to do and the lessons that I'm
giving you today we have to be patient
and the other way we get them to fruit
is again doing that right kind of
pruning not the heading Cuts but instead
thinning cuts and if you can get away
with it consider doing some summer
pruning all right guys thanks for
watching please check out that blog post
I mentioned we'll see you for the next
video hit that like button hit that
subscribe button
take care